something bad happened in this country
and it wasn't the election of Donald
Trump as a 45th president elect it was
the collapse of a country unto itself it
was a rise of white supremacy as once
again a publicly acceptable ideal in the
highest office in this country the
election of that ideal into the House
and Senate but how does that happen how
did the polls get it so wrong wasn't
Clinton set to take it well polls deal
with available numbers they don't deal
with power they don't deal with personal
stories they don't deal with the
complexity of the act of voting they
don't deal with how strong the feeling
of the loss of power can be and also how
intensely private that feeling can be
they don't tell you who's a hidden
supporter for this candidate or that
candidate they also don't tell you who's
going to actually walk out stand in line
make it to the ballot box and vote polls
also don't tell you how powerful a
vision for our country actually is Trump
offered a vision for this country it's
not one that many Americans whether they
voted or not share but enough Americans
did believe in it make America great
again that's a vision it's a vision you
can mark it it starts from a negative
place but it gives you hope and change
you can believe in right and whatever
that great is it's probably subjective
for most voters who elect a Trump may be
great again means being able to say the
words those pesky social justice
warriors will let you say maybe it means
being able to have a stable income
finally maybe it means a Jim Crow
revival or maybe it means just not
Hillary the Democrats didn't offer a
vision they offered the fear of Trump's
vision and that's just not good enough
it's just not enough to say hey we're
not that guy and think you're gonna win
maybe it should be enough but it wasn't
there are people right now in this
country who believed they just took back
their country all this ugliness that
we've seen over this election it's
existed in the private for so long that
there are communities in this country
who've experienced that ugliness day to
day
for decades but whatever lines of
civility existed in the public are in
effect erased what's stopping
individuals from doing what they now
need to do as they see it to take back
their country even more and how does
this impact people of color for instance
who are in the public calling out white
supremacy working day and night to fight
it eradicate it and educate other
Americans about it
what about LGBTQ communities Muslims
undocumented mothers fathers children
are they safe an utterly unqualified
Canada became the president-elect of the
United States and that's still not the
scariest part the scariest part is what
allowed him to get to this point